strange end of the season for miami
dolphins just a couple of years removed
from a playoff berth adam gase is fired
mike tannenbaum is out chris greer stays
as the gm and essentially is in charge
of the football operations hires brian
flores to be the head coach the
expectations are incredibly low and i'd
always prefer shireen low expectations
to high expectations it's a lot easier
to clear that low bar than it is to to
meet when everyone expects you to be a
playoff team and make some noise in
january so i kind of like where the
dolphins are because they're in kind of
a no-lose situation the the question is
how much better can they really be in
one off season with what chris greer and
brian flores are trying to do starting
with trying to find a quarterback a
franchise quarterback for the first time
since dan marino retired 20 years ago
well you know my husband's an orioles
fan and a dolphins fan so i joke about
he needs to find the losingest teams in
basketball and hockey and pick those up
too and
early in the off season i said you know
you're going to have the worst team in
the nfl i no longer believe that i think
this is a mediocre football team i think
it's going to be a little bit better
than people expect however having said
that i don't think they're going to have
a better record than they had last
season i'm just saying i think they're
going to be better than what people
expect them to be which is the worst
team or one of the worst teams in the
nfl and i actually like them at the
quarterback position i love what they've
done in the off season at the
quarterback position they're way better
off than than many maybe most teams in
the nfl at the quarterback position with
the veteran and a guy you expect to be
your franchise guy
yeah and and look
i
so many people expect them to be
absolutely dreadful and they haven't
been absolutely dreadful in a long time
they've been competitive but not
competitive enough we've got one playoff
birth in the last decade uh they haven't
had any success in the postseason but
you know they're trying to build
something now and there's this tension i
think at the top of the organization
between the burning desire to win that
chris greer and brian flores definitely
have i i just wonder how much ownership
really buys into the idea of continuing
this 79 8 and 8 hope to get lucky get to
the playoffs because there really is an
argument to be made that if you take
your lumps
heavily one year and you have that three
and thirteen bottom out and you put
yourself in position to go get your
franchise quarterback
that that that has you set for the next
decade and the question is did they find
their franchise quarterback without
having to bottom out can josh rosen
become the guy who who finally bridges
that gap back to dan moreno because it's
been a long revolving door of not great
quarterbacks for the dolphins since
mourinho retired have we seen enough
from josh rosen have any confidence that
he can come in and be a guy that that we
say wow boy the cardinals really got
that wrong by getting rid of josh rosen
i don't think we've seen it yet but he
was the 10th overall pick for a reason
and i do think he can be that guy and
you know what if he is that guy we're
all gonna say oh my gosh the dolphins
are geniuses what if this guy turns out
to be better than kyler murray and he
could be and if he is then i think the
miami dolphins have hit on this without
having to use that high pick as you said
to get their franchise guy instead the
cardinals used it and they got him
basically for free this is a very low
risk proposition for the miami dolphins
and
the problem to me that they face is to
find out if josh rosen is that guy
they're going to have to play him this
season at some point to find out if he
is that guy otherwise if they're that
bad as you said they've got to go out
and draft a quarterback next year and
that'll be their franchise guys so it
all depends on how ryan fitzpatrick is
going to keep his job as long as this
team can can win football games
initially and if they lose enough games
you've got to get josh rosen in there
and get him in there quickly
i think you need to give rosen every
opportunity to prove he's the right guy
as of week one i mean i i think that if
rosen is gonna become a franchise
quarterback and if he is worthy of being
the 10th overall pick in the draft if he
is worthy of the second round pick the
dolphins sent to arizona to get him even
though they played the board very well
they traded down uh
in the deeper part of round two picked
up an extra second round pick from the
saints by doing that and then sent that
lower second round pick to arizona for
all those things rosen should be better
than ryan fitzpatrick and he should be
able to be the week one starter if he's
not that's alarming but uh you know at
some point you're right they have to
evaluate him this year and they have to
see what they have because they may have
a decision to make next year but they
have him for three years at 6.3 million
total that is peanuts as far as
quarterbacks go the cardinals ended up
paying him over 11 million dollars for
one year so the the dolphins have worked
this well the question becomes how does
it work out from here and as it relates
to the dolphins draft shireen i love the
fact that they got christian wilkins at
13. that there's something about that
there's just an energy you know he came
out and he slammed into roger goodell he
did the jump slam into roger goodell
he's got a great personality now i know
that doesn't make for a great football
player but there's just you know the
dolphins need
someone that gets people excited if it's
not going to be the quarterback and it
hasn't been for a long time it's got to
be another player and i think christian
wilkins is going to be a guy who really
energizes dolphins fans and makes them
feel good again about following a team
that has been mediocre at best for two
decades
i absolutely love that draft pick and
this is a football team that's pretty
good on the back end
maybe really good on the back end and if
they can get that pass rush now i know
they've lost
cameron wake but christian wilkins is
going to be a star in this league i have
no doubts about that i think this was a
great pick
by the miami dolphins
and he improves their defense and
improves their defense right away and
bryant flores is going to improve their
defense too just from a coaching aspect
i think he was a great hire possibly the
best hire in this cycle of coaches
and i do think the dolphins will
eventually win it's not going to be this
year but i do think the dolphins will
take some sort of step this season maybe
not record wise but i think they'll take
a step
and be a better football team overall
even if the record doesn't say that
they're a better football team
we're all constantly evaluating which of
the other teams in the afc east will be
ready to compete to fill the vacuum
whenever the patriots fall off that
assumes the patriots ever do
fall off i'm not ready to admit that
they're ever going to fall off but the
bills in the jets most people would say
are best positioned for now but yeah the
dolphins are just a seasonal way of
exceeding expectations to get us to say
this may be a team that we have to take
seriously again and and i remember you
know sharing when we were growing up the
dolphins were and even though they were
aqua right they were an intimidating
team they were a good team when the
dolphins showed up you were probably
going to lose that day it's been a long
time since that vibe has been around
yeah it certainly has i went to a
thanksgiving day game when the dolphins
played the cowboys and they were that
intimidating team and that team that
everybody wanted to see they had those
personalities that you're talking about
well it wasn't it wasn't the leonlette
game was it
no no this is back in the 70s
yeah oh that they weren't as
intimidating then but they ended up
thanks to leonlette coming out of it
with a victory we got one hour down one
more to go we'll be right back with more
right after this
[Music]
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports